pendant plus de dix ans vous aviez cru
et a été le projectionniste du cinéma
des carmes a été car le métier n'existe
plus avaler par l'arrivée du numérique
ce matin-là il est heureux et un peu
nostalgique
il va nous montrer ce qu'il a fait
pendant des années démonter un vieux
film
la cdu c'est du progiciel une pellicule
35 mm et un film s'appelait histoire de
tango qu'on démonte on va renvoyer donc
dans des stocks sur paris parce que le
film il a il arrive dans des boîtes en
carton de bobines chaque bobine fait
entre 15 et 20 minutes que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de transporter un
film démonte et qu'un film monté ce
qu'un film monté c'est une grosse bobine
cessait pas transportable donc tous les
films avant arriver démonter vous aviez
crew et a donc été obligé de s'adapter
d'évoluer finie la pellicule les films
sont désormais diffusés par voie
numérique saviez comment ça se passe
maintenant pour lancer un film
alors maintenant les films
il arrive ce soit par internet soit par
des disques durs peut-être que celui ci
donc les films moi j enregistre dans une
bibliothèque
ici où je peut stocker une centaine de
films et après suivant si le film je
passe en salle une ou un 7 2 en salle 3
jeux le transfert vers ces deux salles
la bonne je transfère vers un serveur à
l'ordinateur qui est relié aux
projecteurs c'est ça un film maintenant
voilà on s'en rend pas compte ce sont
des fichiers qui sont très lourds ce que
ça fait quand même 150 giga pour un film
normal et pour un film qui en 3d ça peut
monter jusqu'à 250 gigas ou 3 100 giga
qu'est ce que ça te fais toi d'être
passé comme ça du manuel au virtuel
alors au début c'était assez surprenant
mais après il ya un côté pratique parce
que là on sait des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus rapides à manipuler à deux
projectionnistes xavier crew est donc
devenu responsable technique
xavier on va où là on va en salle une on
va les faire des essais pour une séance
qui a lieu demain matin
demain après midi pourquoi si tout va
bien et le film a testé le cercle des
petits philosophes
vous savez ce que c'est que les émotions
l'amour l'amour ça peut être
effectivement une émotion parce que une
émotion c'est donc j'écoute le film
pourra si c'est pas trop fort donc c'est
bon c'est très bien et au niveau de
l'image allait bel donc pour moi c'est
correct pour la séance de mardi
ça c'est aussi ton travail oui dès qu'on
a des cons à nouveau film en général de
test et après je vois à quel moment
commence le générique également pour
pallier les lumières trop tôt ou trop
tard
et puis tout n'est qu'on a une soirée
avec un réalisateur je fais des essais
un petit peu plus long pour voir si tout
va bien pendant le film à différents
moments du film
j'essaye de voir si c'est pas trop fort
parce effort vraiment le son c'est très
important
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
vous la télé
les amis c'est quand même de l'argent
sans argent pays pauvres et ça
[Musique]